[Music]
working there is not let's turn they
need to know we're still here this is
the Teen Titans can anyone hear us we
think we found a way back let's give
everybody what they really want to see
Titans Oh
[Music]
this is gonna be good that looks like us
but better these team Titans were about
character development drama and heart I
used to be so much cooler I want to
watch
[Music]
Oh
whoa
[Music]
what that's how it is and there is no
sixth season to resolve the plots
hanging from the cliffs you handed that
show you monster we think we found a way
back hey everybody its charlie we found
a way to come back now we actually know
what's going on with Teen Titans Season
six because at the end of Teen Titans go
to the movies they had that tag
everybody was wondering what they were
trying to set up or if they were just
trolling now we actually know the truth
of things so I'll explain what's going
on and when this is gonna be coming so
if you're new to the channel I'm doing
giveaways for that DC streaming service
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video the trailer that I attached to the
beginning of this actually comes from
the Teen Titans go to the movies DVD and
blue-ray police that's coming out next
week so Warner Brothers confirm that
this is a genuine project that they
created the other actors Tara Strong
I've been teasing the return of original
Teen Titans we just didn't know what it
was gonna look like now it seems like
what they're doing is Teen Titans vs
Teen Titans go they didn't say how many
episodes is gonna be if it's gonna be a
one-off project like they've gone up
against other versions of themselves
before in previous episodes I'll play
clips from those in a second because
some of them are actually pretty good
The Young Justice clip the original Teen
Titans for now Warner Brothers has not
said whether or not this is like a
full-blown home video release or if it's
just gonna be an episode that will air
on Cartoon Network
the people behind this Warner Brothers
animation typically release at least one
movie per year but next year in January
it's gonna be reign of the Superman they
just dropped a new trailer for that so
right now there's no official release
date but because a lot of the actors do
the same voices for all the different
versions of Teen Titans and Young
Justice it winds up being a little bit
funnier so this is the clip of them
versus Young Justice and then them
versus the classic version of the Titans
if we can't be serious about being
superheroes and who send these cretins
to our base in the croteau a nebula for
further interrogation something tells me
this is only the beginning
Aqualad hello Robin
sweet moves out there I do what must be
done
excuse me there is an emergency in the
SN 185 quadrant that needs my attention
cool cool cool yeah I'll probably head
out there too what on your way to a
pie-eating competition what I did not
wish to say anything but you and your
team have brought nothing but shame to
all real superheroes the Teen Titans are
a disgrace hey you are way off base
buddy there's no difference between our
teams let me do things a little
differently but we're both just trying
to take down the bad guys is that right
quick before they see us
who is ready for another of the girls
night out
[Music]
superheroes are supposed to inspire
hearts and teach valuable lessons about
friendship and life we do that what
lessons like books can be dangerous or
what is better burgers or burritos you
are a mockery of everything the world
holds sacred about heroes come on what
is so bad about being a little silly
from time to time I am all for a good
laugh but the Teen Titans cannot be
serious for one single point good day
but I said good day
I won't waste my breath explaining to
you why classic superhero cartoons are
superior
I'll show you that's the narrator he
explains things to the audience
dancing diodes is it that just lazy
storytelling the narrator to the fence
at this comment it is not lazy
storytelling yes the Young Justice
episode which is called let's get
serious if you guys didn't know Young
Justice season 3 will premiere sometime
in January they released their full
schedule for that DC streaming service
so you can see Young Justice season 3 is
26 episodes
broken into two big parts the first part
will air in January and then the second
batch of episodes will air sometime
during the summer after Doom Patrol we
have the Aquaman movie coming up the
funny thing about that classic Teen
Titans clip is that it's meant to be the
first version of them that ever aired on
television but instead of getting their
own show their segment aired during the
Filmation Superman aqua
an adventure hour so remember like
that's the version of Aquaman that
everybody points to when they think that
it's funny in when Jason Momoa became
Aquaman he's like please just let me
make him cool in fact when they were
making Justice League he said that he
petitioned Zack Snyder and then later
Joss Whedon to remove an Aquaman joke
out from when Batman was coming to find
him
because he felt like it just made all
command way too corny do you talk to
fish the water does the talking the car
comes in a stranger may point away so
I'll be interested to see what the
Aquaman movie feels like in terms of
tone and humor because there are quite a
few jokes during that trailer journey
beyond the edge of the world to the
hidden sea
in the world hands
it would bring destruction
but in her hands the true heir
it would unite all our kingdoms above
and below
what we've written it down first I
memorized it didn't you oh yeah what are
you just say something something trident
so either Momo has chilled out or they
just found a way to write the Aquaman
character during the movie they're just
not quite as corny but just to be clear
about all this Teen Titan season 6 stuff
they're resolving all that within a Teen
Titans go project that will drop next
year there is a new live-action
Titans episode coming on Friday they're
gonna do Robins origin story so we'll
get some more Batman scenes I'll do a
video for that so no worries I've got
some more Marvel coming up but leave all
your video requests in the comments
below while you wait for everything
click here for my brand new flash
episode and click here for brand new
Rick and more to you season 4 thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you